3:00 in the morning 4:00 at night Oh erm
Ava is 46 she's a businesswoman and a
grandmother she's also HIV positive Olga
discovered her status by chance after an
accident put her husband in hospital
[Applause]
after surgery the doctor said they
couldn't figure out what was wrong my
husband had some virus at first I
thought it could be meningitis
it was HIV Olga and her husband had
lived with it for years undetected and
untreated within months her husband was
dead it couldn't be there was no way it
could be HIV that was always somewhere
else in someone else's life
I was always healthy always fit we cross
from Petersburg to the city's government
HIV center where Olga receives treatment
but how cool is her case we redeem the
chauvinist engine we're now seeing the
epidemic entering the wider population
the kinds of patients were seeing
they're not drug users these are people
with families with children who lose
your cat or a medium mewing in most
cases they're being infected by sexual
transmission the poor computer last
year's so reported HIV infections in
Russia top 100,000 and all-time high
doctors estimate that the true figure is
significantly greater of those patients
that do know their status only about 1/3
receive antiretroviral drugs without
them
patients run the risk of infecting their
partners epidemic is a term the Russian
authorities seem desperate to avoid but
with infection rates at an all-time high
it's a problem that's becoming
increasingly harder to ignore critics
argue that the government's response is
hampered by its conservative social
agenda and chronic underfunding
Alden never considered keeping her HIV
status a secret it was never a question
for me I never thought about whether I
should be afraid of other people's
reactions when they heard about it for
me it's all about making sure the same
thing doesn't happen to other people
that's why she decided to tell her story
it's a timely message but one that the
official figures suggest isn't getting
through